mr. Nigel Adams for weeks the British
Parliament has been the scene of chaotic
debates with Prime Minister Theresa May
now caught in between Britain could see
a No Deal exit from the European Union
as early as Friday May is hoping for
lifeline a deadline extension from
Brussels on Wednesday she plans to ask
the EU for more time preferably until
June 30th but she needs help
may is heading to mainland Europe with a
first stop in Belen with German
Chancellor Angela Merkel opposes a hard
brexit but will she support Mays
timetable probably not if it means
breaking ranks with other EU leaders we
as the 27 EU Member States will stand
together and we want to do everything
possible up to the last hour to avoid a
disorderly exit by pratensis Merkel
supports an orderly brexit something May
won't get her here in Paris French
president Emmanuel macron has voiced
concerns about another extension of the
brexit negotiations the you cannot be
held hostage to the resolution of the
political crisis in the United Kingdom
on a long-term basis in Britain there's
little hope that Theresa May can resolve
the brexit issue despite her charm
offensive around Europe's capitals for
more now joined by our political
correspondent Anja Carla so Anja
we've got Theresa May coming across the
channel talking to European leaders
she's going to be visiting Chancellor
Merkel asking for another extension what
kind of reception can she expect from
Chancellor Merkel well yes that's the
great question here today Angela Merkel
has always said she is going to do
everything in order to prevent a no deal
breck said and this is the ground on
which the two leaders are going to talk
today to find a way to avoid this
disorderly brexit but at the same time
it is doubtful
that that may can really expect great
concessions because the the European
leaders have been fairly clear that
there won't be any touching up on the
withdrawal agreement Anglin actually
wants to avoid a disorderly brexit
because this would have a negative
impact on German economy and with all
the uncertainty of with this whole
brexit issue this is the one point that
analysts are can agree on this would
have a heavy impact so the Chancellor
has said where there is a will there
will be away but it's not for Angela
Merkel to to sketch this way so she
expects of Theresa May that she has a
draft for an alternative way she has to
say she has to present an idea what you
would do with the time she would gain
with with that extension a member of
Angela Merkel CDU party has said delay
is not acceptable at all if Teresa maid
doesn't come up with an idea what she's
doing with that time and in addition
Berlin isn't very happy with Great
Britain taking part in the European
elections so maybe Angela Merkel will
back an extension until the 22nd of May
the day before the election but not
until the end of June after meeting with
Chancellor Merkel Theresa May will then
go on to Paris for meetings with French
president manuel McColl our Berlin and
Paris on the same page when it comes to
breaks it no they're not Angela Merkel
is renowned for her patience and in
Manuela macaw a clearly seems to run out
of this virtue he's highly skeptical and
he has said you can't become a hostage
to Great Britain's politics and he
doesn't see any benefit of the other
possible extension furthermore with that
bill the UK Parliament just passed last
night
the influence of Parliament on the whole
process will grow
and it is much harder it will become
much harder for British government to
control the process of the of the brexit
so that makes it more difficult for the
European leaders to accept an extension
so my core will probably take a harder
stance on the whole issue than Angela
Merkel she has always stressed that it
is really important that the remaining
EU members stand united on the question
of the brexit and her spokesperson
yesterday said it is always good to talk
and this didn't really sound as if Mae
could expect much concession and you
kerley a political correspondent thank
you so much